Very little is known about the gulper eel.
This camera-shy deep sea fish is sometimes
called the pelican eel because of the strange
things it can do with its mouth.
Researchers were based out of the Azores Islands
where they have been studying underwater species
for almost 30 years.
They boarded a submarine and plunged 1000
meters below the surface of the water.
Then they waited.
This is the first time the pelican eel has
been seen directly by humans hunting for prey.
An early video from an unmanned submarine
showed the crazy mouth move, but this video
is the first evidence that pelican eels actually
pursue their prey, and don’t just hang out in
the water waiting for it to fall into their mouths.
The scientists hope their footage will help
us to better understand the behavior of the
pelican eel.
And shine some light on how and why it evolved
its balloon-like head.